quand j'étais jeune j'avais beau être
fasciné par harry potter et ses pouvoirs
magiques et quelque chose me dérange et
on n'avait aucune explication d'où ça
sort la magie c'est quoi sa science et
ses limites un moment la différence
entre un moldu est un sorcier elle doit
bien se faire au niveau biologique au
niveau de l'adn aujourd'hui essayons
d'imaginer ce qu'il faudrait changer
dans nos lois de la physique pour rendre
la magie possible comment rendre les
transmutation magique possible c'est un
vieux rêve d'alchimiste transformer le
plomb en or et si je vous disais que
c'est non seulement possible mais que
vous pourriez le faire chez vous enfin
si vous êtes millionnaire la nature d'un
atom est déterminé par une simple
addition combien tu as de proto si vous
avez si proton c'est du carbone si vous
en ajoutez un set la zot vous en ajoutez
10 c'est du chlore pour savoir combien
protons à l'atome que vous voulez vous
avez juste à ressortir votre tableau
périodique des éléments tout y est la
transmutation magique c'est donc
simplement ajouter ou soustraire des
protons à des atomes existant avec
quelques neutrons aussi histoire de
stabiliser la tomme sinon ils base d
intégrer et bien ça c'est complètement
faisable dans la réalité dans les années
1980 les scientifiques sont arrivés à
transformer le bismuth en or pour ça ils
ont bombardé une feuille de bismuth avec
des particules de carbone et de néons le
but était d'ajouter des neutrons au
noyau pour le rendre plus lourd ce noyau
va alors devenir instable et cherchait à
retrouver son étal équilibre pour faire
ça il devra éjecter le surplus de
particules sous forme de protons
neutrons et électro dans le cas du
bismuth à force de perdre des particules
il finit par se transformer en or vous
vous posez sûrement la question pourquoi
ces scientifiques ne sont pas devenus
les hommes les plus riches du monde et
bien parce que ce n'est pas du tout
rentable ça demande une quantité
phénoménale d'énergie en une journée qui
a coûté 5000 $ ils ont réussi à
fabriquer quelques milliers d'atomes
d'or pour pouvoir transmuter une petite
pépite de 28 grammes d'or il faudrait
investir 1 me 2 milliards de dollars
nous on va partir du principe que la
magie n'a pas besoin de bombarder de
protons c'est trop long trop énergivores
trop coûteux non on peut faire plus
simple la magie pourrait agir sur
l'information quantique au niveau des
particules élémentaires je m'explique
prenez un atom il y a le noyau hockey
dans ce noyau ils y allaient protour les
nôtres au hockey eh bien ça ne s'arrête
pas là le proton est lui-même le
regroupement de trois quarks de up est
indemne et pour le neutron celle inverse
de down est un hub pour ajouter un
proton magiquement vous pouvez
simplement transformer un autre ou en
changeant le quark d'hommes en coire cep
c'est non seulement possible mais c'est
un phénomène qui peut se produire
naturellement lorsque le neutron et
isolé de son noyau il se transforme
alors en breton et mais un électron si
au contraire vous voulez retirer un
proton ou un autre on l'a faudra faire
quelque chose d'un peu différent il faut
retirer les gluons qui maintiennent les
quarks ensemble c'est un peu la glu du
coeur des atom c'est comme ça qu'on va
pouvoir transformer le plomb en or par
des milliards 2 milliards d'addition de
soustraction et de conversion quantique
le problème c'est qu'un élément ce n'est
pas que les atomes c'est aussi une
structure connaît le diamant ce n'est
que des atomes de carbone comme votre
mine de crayon leurs différences la
manière dont les atomes sont à ranger
leur structure jeune et maintenant qu'on
augmente la difficulté en parlant de
molécules des structures qui ont une
forme particulière qui va déterminer
leur fonction et leur interaction
transformer l'eau en vin sa demande de
passer de ça à l'une des centaines de
molécules extrêmement complexe qui
constitue le breuvage alcoolique jésus
magicien de rang s c'est jésus comment
rendre la transformation animal possible
dans les films les sorcières peuvent
transformer les gens l'animal d'un coup
de baguette magique mais au fond espace
quoi au niveau du corps à ce moment là
je vous explique l'adn est ce qui
définit tous les êtres vivants et on a
beaucoup de points communs 98 % avec le
chimpanzé 80% avec le chien ou même 35 %
avec les fleurs autant vous dire que
croiser les espèces
c'est pas impossible en 2020 la chine a
même réussi à faire naître un bébé
chimères chimpanzé cochon du coup un
animal gus qui peut se transformer en
animal à volonté c'est juste une
modification de l'adn avant de répondre
à cette question voyons déjà si on peut
modifier l'adn la réponse est oui avec
christopher kas 9 le principe est simple
une enzyme casse neuf peut être
programmé pour découper n'importe quelle
zone de l'adn et la remplacer par une
autre couplé à des cellules souches qui
ont la capacité de devenir tout ce
qu'elles veulent il pourrait être la
nôtre cocktail pour devenir loup garou
mais non c'est une idée reçue votre adn
ça n'est pas vraiment vous l'adn c'est
un plan de construction même pas de
votre corps mais deux protéines qui vont
indirectement vous sculptez introduire
de nouvelles protéines c'est risquer un
dysfonctionnement du corps ou un rejet
et donc la mort quand vous faites
irradié votre adn change aussi mais vous
ne venez pas hulk juste un show de 30 kg
comment rendre la téléportation possible
dans harry potter pour se déplacer
rapidement d'un endroit à un autre les
sorciers utilisent le sort de transe
planage vous vous faites pas getty fier
dans un tourbillon on vous pouvez perdre
des membres comme ron weasley et bien
ces symptômes
ce sont les mêmes lorsque vous approcher
trop près d'un trou noir la gravité tels
que vos pieds ressentent une gravité
plus forte que votre tête le bas de
votre corps donc plus vite que le haut
vous vous étiez comme une ficelle avant
de finir écrabouillé au centre il existe
cependant une théorie qui veut qu'au
centre du trou noir la force
gravitationnelle soit si forte que
l'espace y plier en deux ainsi certaines
zones de l'univers seraient connectées
entre elles et exploserait en continu la
matière aspirer on appelle ça des
troubles ans et ça pourrait s'apparenter
à des portails de téléportation un objet
de ce type pas potentiellement déjà été
détectés du coup ça serait sa transe
planer créé un trou noir d'accord mais
c'est un peu compliqué de faire ça avec
une baguette dans la nature les trous
noirs se forme à partir des toiles
massive qui s'effondrent sous leur
propre poids le plus petit trou noir
observé fait trois fois la masse du
soleil il faudrait donc aux mines mum un
million de fois la masse de la terre
pour invoquer un simple sort de
téléportation ça fait un peu beaucoup
non heureusement il ya une astuce avec
le rayon choir child on peut postuler
que tout objet qu importe sa masse s'il
est compressé en dessous d'un certain
point peut devenir un trou noir par
exemple la terre faudrait la réduire à
une bille de 0 87 cm la magie modifierez
localement la gravité pour pouvoir
compressé n'importe quel objet jusqu'à
ce qu'ils forment un trou noir et hop
voilà votre portail de téléportation
par contre dépêchez vous vu qu'il n'est
pas assez massif il ne sera active que
quelques milliardième de milliardième de
milliardième de seconde
reste un dernier problème comment
détermine la sortie rien n'indique que
la sortie d'un trou noir ne soit pas
défini totalement au hasard avec le
risque de finir de transe planer au fin
fond de la galaxie il nous faut donc une
sorte de balise pour nous signaler le
point d'arriver eh bien ça ça pourrait
être possible avec la téléportation
quantique
en 2009 l'état quantique d'un atome a
été téléporté sur un mètre en 2017 un
photon a été téléportés dans l'espace
c'est fou hein maintenant on n'est
vraiment pas sûr de la téléportation
façon star game il s'agit en réalité de
particules intriquées des photons qui se
comporte comme une seule entité même si
séparer physiquement c'est plus une
sorte d' échanges d'informations que du
transport de matières inutilisable par
la magie en vrai la seule façon
déterminer une position d'arriver à
notre téléportation ça serait de tirer
un laser magique dans l'espace avec un
certain angle qui rebondit sur un miroir
magique qui levait retourner sur terre
est là on peut dire que le laser créé
l'ouverture entre les deux trous noirs
au corps au programme tous les spins des
particules présentes à cet endroit pour
te photocopier quantique mans
c'est magique comment rendre les
invocations magique possible des
sorcières qui se rassemblent autour d'un
pentagramme dessinée avec du sang de
chèvre invoquant en êtres démoniaques
après avoir sacrifié une vierge ça
semble loin d'être rationnel et pourtant
dans les faits ce démon sort d'un
portail vers un autre monde et en
sciences on appelle ça un pont
d'einstein rosen un trou de ver pour les
intimes l'idée qu'avec de l'antimatière
de l'énergie négative on va réussir à
plier l'espace en deux un peu comme avec
le trou noir à la différence que les
trous de ver ici sont inertes et donc ne
vont ni vous aspirez ni vous expulsez
juste vous faire passer d'un point à
l'autre fabriquée l'antimatière et la
partie la plus simple il faut accélérer
un proton proche de la vitesse de la
lumière il le faire s'écraser sur un mur
en uranium on l'a déjà fait il ya en
termes d'énergie ça pompe un tiers de ce
que la ville de genève a besoin pour
fonctionner en une journée le shaq a
produit beaucoup de particules dont un
antiproton mais ça durait dix n'est que
de quelques nanosecondes si on ne fait
rien pour pouvoir l'utiliser il faut le
confiner dans un champs
électromagnétiques comme on a fait aux
cernes oui là c'est bien de
l'antimatière sur cette cloche en verre
le problème c'est qu'avec cette
technique on est capable de produire que
1 gramme d'antimatière en un peu plus de
1000 milliards d'années dans le monde
d'harry potter la magie serait une force
capable d'écraser des protons à vitesse
lumière pour produire de l'antimatière
qui va plier l'espace temps vers une
nouvelle zone de l'univers le problème
et il est toujours le même comment
détermine ou et le trou de sortie là
dessus on n'a aucune réponse et surtout
selon stephen hawking si un tel
phénomène était possible il serait
tellement instable que la lumière elle
même n'aurait pas le temps de le
traverser cligne des yeux et le portail
est déjà fermée le seul moyen de le
stabiliser sa serait de l'alimenter en
énergie négative à concepts
mathématiques aux limites de la science
fiction dont on ne sait pas comment elle
se produit ni si elle existe vraiment on
va dire que c'est magique et si la magie
était en fait une elle force de
l'univers on le sait l'univers est régi
par quatre forces fondamentales chacune
associée à une particule
l'électromagnétisme avec le photon les
interactions fortes avec le bouillon et
les interactions faible avec les blues
il en manque une dernière la force
gravitationnelle
elle serait porté par une particule
théorique jamais observé le graviton ou
pas on ne sait pas si la magie devait
exister elles seraient forcément
transporté par une nouvelle particule
appelons la particule m elle aura besoin
d'être beaucoup plus puissante que les
quatre autres forces fondamentales à
l'échelle subatomiques mais également à
l'échelle humaine l'existence d'une
telle particules mais pas forcément de
la science fiction elle pourrait très
bien exister dans un des plis de notre
univers tels que la théorie des cordes
le conçois il existerait au total onze
dimensions on a nos trois dimensions
spatiales et la dimension du temps les
huit autres seraient tellement compacte
et miniatures qu'elles seraient
indétectables
elle pourrait se combiner et prendre 10
puissance 200 formes différentes
notre univers ne correspondant qu'à une
seule de ses possibilités mais vous
savez le plus fou c'est que cette forme
dicterait les constantes de notre
univers c'est grâce à elle qu'un
électron à une charge d'exactement moins
1,6 x 10 puissance moins 19 coups longs
parce qu'il y aurait très bien pu être
autre chose la masse des particules et
la vitesse de la lumière sont de simples
chiffres qui peuvent théoriquement être
modifié imaginez si la vitesse de la
lumière ne serait que d'un kilomètre
heure imaginez s'il l'oxygène et l atome
le plus lourd c'est peut-être le cas
dans une autre dimension postuler une
telle chose permettrait d'expliquer la
nature même de la matière noire ou
pourquoi la gravité est une force aussi
faible par rapport aux trois autres
forces fondamentales les trous noirs
seraient ici que des fuites de cette
force à travers les multis vert on
dirait un délire pseudo scientifique
mais il ya vraiment des scientifiques
qui ont postulé c'est grâce à ça que nos
magiciens peuvent disposer d'une énergie
infini ne pioche pas dans leur cellule
ni même dans les atomes de leur corps
mais dans les plis quantique des
dimensions de l'espace une énergie
monstrueuse y est en cash et les
sorciers serait donc capable de
manipuler localement les dimensions
microscopique d'un objet ou d'une zone
donnée afin de transférer leurs mots de
la bible à notre monde
ces points restent à résoudre à un gros
souci comment font-ils tout ça juste par
la pensée on pourrait extrapoler que les
sorciers soit capable avec leur cerveau
des maîtres toute une palette d'onde
interagissant avec la particule m c'est
pas délirant notre corps humain actuel
et mais déjà cinq types d'onde
détectables à la surface de notre g
delta d'état alpha beta gamma mais pour
beaucoup ça veut rien dire c'est juste
les reliquats de notre activité
cérébrale après je vous rappelle qu'on
essaie d'expliquer scientifiquement la
magie chipoter pas et justement qu'est
ce que vous avez pensé de nos
explications j'espère que la vidéo vous
a plu pensez à vous abonner pour plus de
contenu scientifique et à mettre le tout
il a été l'amour allez les amis
[Musique]